[Musique]
unanimement sur la gravité des maladies
pour nous forcer à nous vacciner alors
on va faire simple la polio s attaquent
à notre système nerveux central
elle peut provoquer des paralysies qui
peuvent même aller jusqu'à paralyser les
muscles qui nous font respirer la
rubéole elle peut entraîner des
malformations congénitales ou la mort du
foetus
chez les femmes enceintes l'hépatite b
elle peut dégénérer en cirrhose ou un
cancer du foie
la rougeole elle peut atteindre le
cerveau et les organes qui a autour et
causé des encéphalites il ya une jeune
fille non vaccinés de 16 ans qui en est
morte en juin dernier à marseille et je
vous parle pas du pneumocoque du
méningocoque de l'haemophilus influenzae
qui peuvent causer des méningites et je
vous parle pas non plus des autres
maladies mais potentiellement elles sont
toutes mortelle et contagieuse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]